[Music]
on the plains of the serengeti a dung
beetle rolls his perfectly sculpted ball
of dung away from competitors
in this canadian river a beaver rushes
to reinforce her dam as it threatens to
burst
as the snowball thunders down the
mountainside gaining momentum the arctic
foxes run for cover i can't stand these
nature programs always the same story
and not a rational actor in sight
what else is on
it's april 1954 and vietnamese
nationalists are on the verge of victory
against french forces fighting for
control of vietnam their victory could
lead to an independent vietnam under
communist leader ho chi minh the united
states president dwight d eidenhauer is
holding a press conference to comment on
these developments
well
if you really must
eisenhower claims that by virtue of what
he calls the falling domino principle
communist control of vietnam would be
the beginning of a disintegration that
would be certain to cause incalculable
loss
the beatles and the beavers may be
beyond my reach but surely here's
someone i can reason with
[Music]
now
mr president
let's take a deep breath shall we
it's a big leap or one might say a long
slide from communist governance of
vietnam to the global spread of
authoritarian communist regimes
it's as if we were to say you were
clothed now you're in your underwear so
soon everyone in the world will be
completely naked
don't worry i may have that power but i
promise not to use it now as i was
saying this kind of argument where one
step let's call it a kicks off a string
of events that inevitably culminates in
an extreme scenario let's call it z
is known as a slippery slope many such
arguments focus on catastrophe but the
slope to an extreme positive outcome can
be just as slippery
the trouble with this kind of argument
is that in presenting z as the
inevitable outcome of a it almost always
overstates the likelihood that z will
happen if a happens why
allow me to trouble you with some math
let's assume for the sake of argument
that taken individually each step
between a and z
is independent from the others and very
likely 99
so the probability that a causes b that
b causes c that c causes d and so on is
each 99
even so each additional step adds an
opportunity to alter the outcome and a
is only 78 percent likely to lead to z
far from an inevitability
if there's a 95 percent likelihood of
each step the chance that a leads to z
plummets to about 28
if there's a 90 likelihood at each step
still very likely by most standards the
chance that a leads to z
is only 7
and if 24 of the 25 steps between a and
z are 99 likely and 1 is 50 percent
likely the chance that a leads to z goes
down from 78
to 39
back to your situation i won't deny you
have reason to be concerned you're
warily watching as powerful
authoritarian communist regimes in the
soviet union and china try to spread
their form of governance but let's take
a look at the chain of events you
suggest you say that the countries
surrounding vietnam would all soon fall
under communist rule that this would
result in a loss of essential trade with
these countries for others that with no
non-communist nations left to trade with
japan would be pressured towards
communism and that this in turn would
threaten australia and new zealand
your ultimate fear if i may presume is
that this will in turn threaten the
united states
is this a possibility
sure
where i take issue is with your
comparison to dominoes these complex
real-world events are not in fact like
dominoes where when the first one falls
it becomes a certainty that the last
will fall
for any one of these events a number of
possible outcomes could result each
affecting the other events in different
ways the possibilities are not a chain
they're a web
[Music]
it's 1975 and after 20 years of conflict
and several million lives lost north
vietnamese forces have taken control of
the capital of south vietnam the war is
over and all of vietnam is under
communist control
communist regimes have come to power in
neighboring laos and cambodia where the
regime will be responsible for the
deaths of an estimated quarter of all
cambodians
[Music]
wait there's more
that first step you were trying to avoid
happened but the end result you
predicted did not as for the steps
between a few happened many did not
decades afterward your fellow humans are
still debating why events unfolded the
way they did
and this is the trouble with slippery
slope arguments they focus exclusively
on extreme outcomes assigning those
outcomes a degree of certainty or
inevitability that rarely corresponds to
reality they divert attention from other
more likely possibilities foreclosing
discussions that might be more
productive
and that's when they're made in good
faith slippery slope arguments can also
be intentionally structured to take
advantage of people's fears whatever
your position on an issue it's easy to
come up with an extreme outcome that
suits your aims
best to avoid them entirely
eh
[Music]
humans will fall for every pitfall in
existence won't they
what's that
you think you won't
all right let's see if you can outsmart
the fallacy that sent hundreds of
innocent people to jail
with this video